Hey Andrea,
how's it going?
Good.
How are you?
Serratia.
Pretty good.
Do you mind if I ask you 67 questions?
Sure.
Why not?
What is one thing you really like about bitcoin?
That it takes power away from centralized institutions that gives it to people.
Favorite park of the software stack.
Um,
the peer to peer components.
Your hoses,
the less talk bitcoin podcast.
Describe it in one word.
Uh,
three people who have great chemistry,
chatting about stuff from different perspectives,
not technical,
but a bit of everything.
Political,
technical,
social.
What was the last project you worked on?
Oh,
let's see.
Um,
the Internet of money.
Volume two,
which the book I published three days ago.
If you could spend an evening with one famous person,
who would it be?
Ooh,
that's a hard one.
Um,
but a bit confused.
bridge Feinman uh,
he died unfortunately.
What do you do to relax?
I fly planes.
Do you Miss California?
Yes.
It's the one place in the world outside of Greece where I can really make a
Greek salad.
Last thing you made with your hands.
Oh,
let's see.
A drone.
Um,
I built one myself.
Where is a lot of blockchain development happening right now?
Um,
mostly California,
bizarrely enough.
What advice would you give yourself 10 years ago?
Uh,
be more confidence and don't question your opinions.
What website do you waste time on Reddit for too much.
Last person you emailed.
Oh,
let's see.
Um,
Yo,
you get an all expenses paid trip to one city.
Where do you go?
Boy.
Buenos ares.
Would you visit Mars?
Yes.
What is one thing you can't live without?
My smart phone.
Where do you envision bitcoin will lead us to a more equitable world.
What texts editor do you use?
Um,
atom or vim.
What open source library do you really like?
A Pi coin.
The Python Library for Bitcoin.
What's one of your favorite movies?
Who,
let's see.
I guess the Matrix.
Really.
What is something you do to come up with project ideas?
Um,
I sleep on them.
What is one of your hobbies outside of blockchain?
Well,
um,
again,
that's a flying planes and learning how to be a good pilot.
What was the first program you've ever made?
It was a,
a simple game on the ZX spectrum in 1981.
What's a music genre you're currently into?
A deep house and ambient electronica.
Is there a programming language you don't like?
Chapa script?
Favorite professor?
Um,
my high school physics professor programming language of choice for blockchain
development.
Python.
What is one area of distributed computing that interests you?
A lot.
Who?
Uh,
well,
other than Bitcoin is distributed information security.
What does a misconception people have about bitcoin that,
uh,
it's all about money.
Maybe one person you really admire.
Um,
right now I'm really digging your videos.
Rush.
What's the most beautiful thing in the world?
Um,
Ooh,
that's a hard one.
MMM,
don't pass.
What do you want to work on the most?
Um,
machine learning applications in blockchain.
What are the people you've met at blockchain conferences like?
Well,
it depends.
If it's a blockchain banking conference,
it's mostly full of Douche bags.
Uh,
and if it's a bitcoin conference,
it's full of Cypherpunks and I really dig cypherpunks.
What is one thing that excites you?
Um,
meeting people who care more about the projects that passionate about than
money.
Best advice you've ever received?
Um,
be authentic.
What's the bravest thing you've ever done?
Ooh,
my first solo flights in a plane.
Who is your favorite computer scientist?
A favorite.
That would be Alan Turing.
Thank you.
Need a phd to do blockchain development?
Uh,
no.
I would hope so.
I hope not because I don't have one.
We'll the singularity happening.
It's already happening.
What is one area of blockchain that doesn't get enough love?
Um,
let's see.
Uh,
the fact that decentralization is the most important thing,
not money.
What is the meaning of life doing what you love the most and doing it
authentically with all of your heart?
What was the last thing that frustrated you?
Uh,
trying to book a taxi in Helsinki where the taxi cartel has kicked out tuber.
What's your spirit animal?
A honey badger.
Favorite scientist.
Richard Fineman.
If you had a time machine,
when would you visit?
Um,
a hundred years from now in the future.
Tell me a secret about yourself.
Just one.
Uh,
let's see.
Mm.
Secret about myself.
MMM.
Don't know.
Pass.
Where would you like to yourself in the next five years?
I actually really like where I am right now.
So I'd like to be able to do what I do today.
Favorite Linux distro?
A deputy who is one person you would love to collaborate with?
Um,
let's see.
Personal.
I'd love to collaborate.
I can't answer serratia again.
Can I?
Sure.
Have you ever been in love?
Yes.
I'm currently a love.
What's the best cryptocurrency to invest in?
Um,
invest in your skills.
Have you built an APP with blockchain that you use in your day to day life?
Uh,
yes.
Um,
a,
uh,
seed storage management and key and signing application called granary.
What's something you've learned in the past month?
Ooh,
uh,
let's see.
Um,
how to work better with Amazon's machine learning publishing algorithms.
What does one really cool use case for blockchain that you haven't seen done
yet?
A large scale remittances to third world countries.
Do you think will create mainstream decentralized apps in your lifetime?
Uh,
yes,
absolutely.
If you ran the world,
what is one law you didn't act,
um,
disbanding the authority that allowed me to run the world?
What's a problem that you would love to see solved?
Um,
concentration of power in fewer and fewer hands.
What is a risk that comes from blockchain?
Uh,
that it's co-opted,
um,
by centralized powers and has to be disrupted yet again by something else.
Who is one person you looked up to when you were in college?
Um,
my English literature teacher.
What's a problem that you would love to see sold?
A reputation and identity management?
What is it?
Who is what,
what were you like as a kid in grade school?
Ooh,
uh,
awkward,
shy,
unsure of myself and very,
very geeky.
What resource do you use to learn the most about the latest breakthroughs in
blockchain?
Um,
I read what's something that excites you about the future?
well,
right now.
I mean it's really simple.
I'm excited by decentralize the open public blockchains.
If you were to start from scratch today,
what is the learning resource you would use to learn blockchain development?
Um,
I think I tried to learn more about javascript pro crabbing all this three
because it's a weakness of mine and I'd also tried to learn more about machine
learning.
Awesome.
Well thanks Andres for answering those questions.
Thank you.
So you have a good one.
Take care.